this is a Fox News Alert North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un has proposed a
face-to-face meeting with President
Trump about his country's nuclear
weapons program good evening welcome to
tucker carlson tonight fox's chief White
House correspondent John Roberts has
been on this story and he has details at
this hour John well this is an
extraordinary moment in history Tucker
just for the very fact that we heard
from the White House tonight that the
President of the United States has
agreed to meet with the president of
North Korea I mean nobody thought that
anything like this could ever happen
unless it was under the most
extraordinary of circumstances but this
is kind of from a beginning level you
know Kim jong-un had talks with South
Korean officials earlier this week
though South Korean officials came to
the White House today to say that Kim is
committed to the denuclearization of the
North Korean Peninsula and he held out
that olive branch for a meeting with
President Trump President Trump who was
said in the past many times he'd be
happy to meet with Kim agreed but this
is aiming toward the denuclearization of
the North Korean Peninsula this is not
about freezing North Korea's nuclear
program as this happened so many times
in the past only to watch them cheat
president Trump is making it clear that
he wants kim jeong-hoon to give up his
nuclear program a statement from the
press secretary just a short time ago
will pass along to you president trump
greatly appreciates the nice words of
the South Korean delegation and
president moon he will accept the
invitation to meet with Kim jong-un at a
place in time to be determined
we look forward to the denuclearization
of North Korea in the meantime all
sanctions and maximum pressure must
remain the question of where is probably
one of the biggest questions right now I
would assume that President Trump is not
going to go to Pyongyang in North Korea
to meet with Kim jong-un
I don't expect that Kim jong-un would
come to the United States because he
might fear that it'll be thrown in
American jail and never see the light of
day ever again not that that would
happen so it may be that they choose
potentially South Korea right there
along the border and Panmunjeom which
will be the site of the talks between
South Korea's president moon jae-in and
Kim jong-un later in May or maybe it's a
third country some some neutral
somewhere else in the world where
everyone can meet how did we get to this
point the White House just walking us
through that in a conference call right
now but Chung u Young who is the North
the South Korean national security
adviser said in the statement outside
the White House here that it was due to
president Trump's program of maximum
pressure that North Korea came to the
table they said that while Kim is
committed to the denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula he also understands the
joint military exercises between South
Korea and the United States must
continue a president Trump is you'll
remember Tucker came under an
extraordinary amount of criticism for
his tough-minded approach toward North
Korea a lot of people were saying he
wanted to start a war with the North it
would seem that exactly the opposite has
happened rather than the missiles flying
it looks like there will be talks and it
really is when you look at everywhere we
were up until this point an
extraordinary moment in history chucker
it's astounding John was there any
mention of the role if any that China
played in this I think this was very
much a behind-the-scenes sort of thing
when you talk about the the program of
maximum pressure that wasn't just the
United States that was the United States
and a number of other countries first
and foremost among them China President
Trump is push Xi Jinping time and time
again to get tougher with North Korea to
increase the sanctions to to to put the
squeeze on a North Korean banks to to
not allow workers in North Korea to save
workers North Korean workers in China to
send money back to North Korea we don't
know exactly how much China did in this
particular case it seemed like it was
limited but at this moment it appears
like it may have been enough so we'll
see where this goes
nobody is under any illusions here in
the United States that kim jeong-hoon
they might think that he's sincere but
nobody thinks that he's not potentially
paying playing fast and loose here
we had john bolton the former UN
Ambassador on our air the other day
saying that he thinks that they're just
trying to buy time so that they can
complete their nuclear weapons program
then they've got a very big bargaining
chip but they're looking at this
optimistically here at the White House
Tucker thinking that this may be the
opening that the United States has
waited for
tried for for an awfully long time well
it's unexpected to say the least
jean-robert said the white house thank
you very much thanks dr. Eric as
Deanna's is a North Korea expert and
director of Defense studies at the
center for the national interest he
joins us tonight Harry I don't know
anybody any of the geniuses running our
foreign policy in Washington who
predicted anything like this well I
certainly didn't that's that's for
certain
I actually thought there's a better
chance we'd be at nuclear war with North
Korea then there'd be peace talks
but there's something we're missing
Tucker there's a little bit of context
South Korean press about two weeks ago
came out with some reports that were
fascinating they actually speculated
that North Korea was actually on the
edge of financial bankruptcy by October
their foreign exchange reserves are
probably going to be exhausted and their
dollar reserves are gonna be asset
so that means North Korea is essentially
bankrupt you can't build a lot of
nuclear weapons and a lot of missiles
when you have no money to do it to pay
all the different spies and people to
bring those materials back right you
can't also feed your people that way so
I do think the North Koreans might be
trying to buy some time here but I also
think that that Kim jong-un's newfound
pragmatism there might be a bigger
reason for us so what do you make of
this Kim pledge that North Korea will
refrain from any further nuclear or
missile tests as long as we're talking
that's the other caveat to that point so
it guesses as long as that both sides
are negotiating and we're trying to
figure something out that then they
won't test there's a bigger point to all
this what I would urge president Trump
to do meet with Kim jong-un throw the
Hail Mary history shows us sometimes
these things can actually happen and
work out I think there's anything wrong
with that but what this administration
cannot do tucker is give him any bribes
give him any economic incentives the
North Koreans have tried that in the
past to come to the table that would be
the wrong move and that would be a
mistake huh so what it what is the
gambit continued pressure I guess in the
words of South Korea I think what we
need to do is we need to test North
Korea's intentions maybe they're sincere
maybe they are willing to come to the
negotiating table because we have to
remember something here
the North Koreans time is against them
their economy is a disaster it's worth
something like 14 billion dollars
South Korea's is worth something like
1.2 trillion some day the North Korean
state will collapse and I think Kim
realizes this so this myth this may be a
historic moment I never thought I would
see this before probably
in decades so I think Trump has to
explore him and he may be the one
president who would actually do this she
would go meet with North Korean leader
is he going to stop on his way in Oslo
to get the Nobel Peace Prize he should
be given the nobody if he if he landed
this if he closes the ultimate deal of a
lifetime you give that man the Nobel
Prize there's no question but let's be I
mean the chances of that are right
around zero I think of getting the Nobel
Peace or Obama for getting elected so I
got do anything yeah I'm aware
yeah yeah you know what Trump's gotta
explore so what happens I mean just to
gain this out a little bit and it's
obviously this is speculative but the
endgame of course is reunification the
Koreas becoming one country again what
would that mean for everyone else means
a lot of good it means a lot of bad let
me the bad is is the toughest part the
cost to reunify North Korea with South
Korea there's probably something like 10
trillion dollars you're talking about
having to build roads bridges take care
of their people that the economics of
that would be totally insane plus you
would have China and Japan very nervous
about what a strong Korea would mean for
the region think just thinking that
through is is just astronomical huh and
China would not be in favor and Japan
would not be in favor
I don't think Japan I think it could've
in some in the long term China I think
it would be one of their biggest fears
well we're thinking ahead this but for
the moment this is really it's amazing
just again as usual no one in DC
predicted it Harry great to see you
thanks doctor